and the ceo of investment bank jeffries
rich handler fired off an email
yesterday
to show his appreciation for junior
bankers working
long hours analysts and associates can
choose from a peloton bike
a mirror home workout system or an apple
package that includes an ipad
apple watch and airpods with applecare
in his email handler said it's quote the
very least we can do
now the company insists the rewards have
been in the works for weeks and weeks
and are not in response to recent
headlines about overworked analysts
on wall street scarlet i think you know
what this is related to
yeah you're referring to goldman sachs
the most wall street of wall street
firms that's trying to make peace with
some of its junior bankers
this is after they aired their
grievances in the most meta of ways
through an online slide presentation
titled working conditions survey
that they shared with their managers and
then it went viral on social media
according to the 13 respondents in the
survey goldman jr bankers work an
average of 100 plus hours per week they
have no time to eat or shower
and they can only get five hours of
sleep per night
goldman says it is listening to their
concerns and will take multiple steps
to address them maddie and i are of
course fascinated by all this so we're
bringing in bill keenan now to discuss
it with us
bill was once a junior investment banker
at deutsche bank he wrote a book about
it called discussion materials
he left the industry and he's now ceo of
airmail which is the digital magazine
launched by grading carter
bill always great to speak with you
these junior bankers have a point
there's clearly no
work life balance there but also small
violin here
this is part of the deal they get paid
really well they get fleece vests that
say goldman sachs on it they get those
cool gym bags i mean
pretty much anyone who goes into banking
at goldman sachs knows what they're
getting into don't they
well thank you guys for having me on i
think for sure
um when when you see you know what
you're
you're getting into when you sign up i
think like you said
um i think my first gut reaction is is
what you touched on the fact that
these they resort to creating a pitch
deck
is kind of kind of tells the whole story
um
because that's the only way to
communicate kind of
the way for them to be heard and it
tells you a lot about
i think you know when you talk about the
culture of a bank and they they couldn't
just
there wasn't anyone there to go to so
let's you know
float a viral uh pitch deck and and i th
the other thing i say charlotte is
charlotte is the 13 respondents having
put in numbers
in in those decks you always have to be
careful because i made up about 90
of those numbers so i want to be careful
with with how much we read into that but
but definitely uh yes it's it's it's an
issue
bill definitely appreciate the honesty
there and you mentioned this going viral
i think one of the reasons scarlett and
i talked about it going viral is because
a lot of these comments are kind of
relatable for a lot of people who
struggle with their jobs i want to point
out
one particularly uh savage quote from
the deck
one banker saying i've been through
foster care this is
arguably worse bill what is your
reaction to that quote i mean i'm
wondering is this just a generation of
young people who
aren't willing to accept the terms of
wall street and
you know the kind of hazing of this
environment being sort of a right of
passage
well i mean that's that's horrifying to
think that someone if that's what
happened that's how they feel
you know i when i look at this i think
what what are some of the solutions
and and it's funny because when i went
to the end of the deck and and some of
these
points that their takeaways there on the
last page i'd actually
disagree with with a number the first
being
like you know they talk about the being
pencils down
meaning basically stop work you know 12
hours before deck
is is due to go out or a meeting's
supposed to happen and from my
experience
i mean the way banking works is no one
spends any time
you got to feel like you're always
working so you spend a couple weeks on
these things and then it's a mad dash
for the last 12 hours so why not just
not do anything
until the last 12 hours make it a
painful 12 hours
but just have it be limited to that 12
hours and then
you know the 90 hours a week honestly
because the
the system is so inefficient i think i
think
you're not actually working the problem
there is that you're on call
in essence like you're like a doctor you
have to sit there and it's almost worse
because you don't know
like think of the anguish you go through
when you know something bad is about to
happen but you just don't know you can't
like
see it it's not tangible yet right so
it's almost worse waiting
and and so if you can basically say like
this i i remember my favorite vp
said hey he'd send me an email the next
24 hours are going to be awful
i expect you to share this with everyone
in the bullpen and at least then i know
it's like this is gonna be bad for 24
hours but
but he wouldn't make it you know over
the course of two weeks creating a deck
you know market updating all this
nonsense okay bill you're clearly still
traumatized from your years at deutsche
bank i mean it's very clear
and i mean one thing again that we're so
taken by
in this deck is all these charts there's
a pie chart on excessive monitoring and
micromanaging apparently
83 of the respondents the 13 respondents
feel that there was
too much monitoring they've also
quantified how their physical health has
worsened there was a 6.7
point drop a pretty steep arrow that
goes down
again all visually presented how come
people spend so much time on these decks
i mean you talk about these presentation
decks
i don't recall a lot of people reading
them from
cover to cover and and using any of the
information in there especially if
you're making up numbers like you just
said
why do bankers spend so much time on
these decks i i it's a crutch i think
when i mean the meetings that i went to
it's just kind of covering your bases as
i remember the one
the the the most successful md's that i
worked for
we'd go in and it was a conversation
about their kids and then it was a
handshake and
you know the deal was was done and i
think this is something that's maybe
a newer thing to it just makes you feel
like hey
i don't really know what i'm talking
about but here's like a thousand pie
charts and tons of colors and gradients
that you know does anything is anything
interesting to you here like i
and and and i think it's just a way to
kind of corroborate i've done a lot of
work like
you know and it makes you feel good like
you know but but as far as actually
getting
getting anything done i agree i think
it's you know
it's it's like i got the right answer
but i didn't show my work when you're in
school but
but ultimately um i think it's just the
way it's definitely evolved and you have
so much more access
now you know it's not just going through
an sec filing you've got these facts
that and
and more i mean there's all these
databases full of numbers so it's
yeah you can kind of get lost in the
weeds and forget what the point of the
whole thing is
and bill we should mention that this is
a really serious issue here i mean a few
years ago
uh bank of america intern did die three
years ago or i'm sorry for working
after working for three straight days so
this is a systemic issue in banking
right how much of the banks
have the banks changed their approach to
junior bankers
following that death yeah i mean that's
that that's a
another horrifying thing to to think
that that happened it just fixed
you know give you some insight into what
you know
these kids are being taken advantage of
and and i think when you come right from
school you have no
other you know i came from business
school i had i did stuff before out in
the world and i had
an understanding of sometimes you know
this is
i want to be treated like a human and
maybe this is i'm being taken advantage
of and
being able to stand up for yourself i
think that's harder to do when you come
right out of college like some of these
analysts do
or i guess all of them um but i i think
i think
you know when when you hear something
like that this this this
starts this is like a leadership thing
and you know i
i'm not just talking about uh somebody
going and jetting off and
and in the news i'm talking like i saw i
saw a response that
from from the goldman seo that said this
is a
you know he's upset and it's a
collaborative apprenticeship business
and
and it's to me that's laughable because
i mean i think of an apprentice like a
cobbler like i i've nev there was
nothing about
the environment being an apprenticeship
that might have been back in the day
you know when when he was doing it but
people md's are have allegiances to
money and their clients and they will go
to whatever bank
so you know to have
to have some leadership to to actually
take action and and um
yeah i i i mean it's seriously spiraled
out of control with things like that
i don't have the answer that's why i'm
no longer in it but um
bill sounds like you made the right
decision and you're doing far better
because of it i think at the end of the
day it's just that banking has lost its
shine it's no longer the sexy job that
people aspire to that
it once was thank you so much bill
keenan